he's a really nice guy right I've been  around him my whole life or for the last  10 years and uh I just wish him well you  know I I honestly yeah a lot of people  aren't disappointed and offended and  hurt by it but now he's just spend it on  I get it and just saying he's saying  what's in I don't blame him for being  offended I'm offended by it okay yeah  um but  um something's gone Kanye's Kanye yeah  so absolutely  um electric political analysis there  from Caitlyn Jenner and by the way the I  wish him well stuff I know that this is  sort of like apropos of nothing but it  did remind me of When Donald Trump was  asked about jilane Maxwell the  um sex trafficker former girlfriend of  the late Jeffrey Epstein and Trump could  think of nothing else to say other than  he wishes her well as well I'm wondering  uh do you feel that she's going to turn  in powerful men how do you see that  working out I don't know I haven't  really been following it too much I just  wish her well exactly